did you enjoy doing that film I did I
loved it and I remember going to West I
was like listen I want to do the most
gruesome death scene ever and he was
like really I said yes go at me I said
and I just one I want to die a terrible
death and so he was like okay and so
that's what we did I'm so happy to meet
you to get to know you I really feel
like I have a whole new wildly beautiful
cool perspective on you I feel like I
relate to you and I feel like there is
so much for the reader in here so
congratulations thank you I appreciate
on this book thank
you now I am so excited because Jada
Memoir Worthy is on sale everywhere and
it is a New York Times bestseller but
today everyone in the audience is going
to go home with a copy we make this for
you take it with you
[Music]
w